the united states britain and australia
are forming a new security alliance for
the indo-pacific region the country's
leaders say the alliance called orcis
will help them better to share defence
capabilities it is also being seen as a
way of countering china's growing
military posturing in the region
flanked by his allies u.s president joe
biden announced a new chapter in foreign
policy the united states australian
united kingdom have long been faithful
and capable partners and we're even
closer today
today we're taking another historic step
to deepen and formalize cooperation
among all three of our nations and
because we all recognize the imperative
of ensuring peace and stability in the
indo-pacific over the long term
for the uk the alliance marks a return
to a post-brexit global britain we will
have a new opportunity
to reinforce britain's place at the
leading edge of science and technology
strengthening our national expertise
and perhaps most significantly
the uk
australia
and the us
will be joined
even more closely together
china was the elephant in the room
none of the leaders mentioned the
country by name but its economic
sanctions on australia and pursuit of
dominance in the region are thought to
be the main reasons for the alliance
now australia will begin the process of
procuring a nuclear-powered attack
submarine
the first major initiative of august
will be to deliver a nuclear-powered
submarine fleet for australia
over the next 18 months we will work
together to seek to determine the best
way forward to achieve this
the august countries aren't the only
ones taking precautions
taiwan recently held five days of army
exercises in response to ongoing chinese
military drills nearby
it's the kind of delicate diplomatic
situation that the new alliance will
hope to influence in the future
for more on this i'm now joined by scott
lucas he's an ex-professor of
international politics at the university
of birmingham in the united kingdom
professor give us the background to this
new alliance how did it come about and
why now
well for each of the three countries
there are different motives
for australia there is the specific
motive
that its deal with france in 2016 for
conventional powered submarines
uh the cost had risen to 90 billion
dollars there had been delays it didn't
appear it was going to get what it
wanted this is now an alternative for
nuclear-powered submarines which is an
upgrade uh they have longer range they
can stay in the water longer
for the united kingdom this is a chance
after the brexit departure isolating
itself from europe to say we're global
britain we are very important with a
focus on the indo-pacific region and for
the united states it's a sign in the
aftermath of afghanistan we have
alliances we are a world leader and of
course it may be a sign although it
wasn't mentioned that this is a
toughening of washington's line
vis-a-vis china in the near future
so in concrete terms uh what's this uh
cooperation gonna look like uh how far
does it extend will this be an eastern
nato in a way
i think we need to be careful before
making all those leaps remember this is
specifically just an agreement about
submarines
not even submarines with nuclear weapons
australia cannot have those under the
nonproliferation treaty
it does have the potential to be more so
for example do you have permanent basing
facilities in australia for the boats
the ships of other countries the uk and
the us included uh do you have other
arrangements in the pacific for
cooperation but to call this in eastern
nato well two things first of all
remember that china is still australia's
number one trading partner so do you
really want to provoke confrontation
with beijing by having a defense
alliance across the entire region and
secondly
you to have a nato you would need other
countries to come into it and do south
korea japan the philippines really want
to join that type of pact given their
own complex relationship with china
so will this be
a deterrent to china
i think china's assessing its position
right now uh i think it's notable that
although the chinese embassy
in the united states said this is a cold
war mentality neither of the communist
party's leading english language
newspapers global times or china daily
even mention the us uk australia
agreement this morning so i think
beijing will assess this as one part of
its calculations because as much as
we're talking about the defense alliance
today remember that china's foremost
push is for an alternative economic
system
the belt and road initiative and that
alternative economic system is a
different way of approaching global
relations than simply saying let's have
some nuclear-powered submarines
scott lucas is there formed professor of
international politics at the university
of birmingham thank you very much
professor
thank you
you